[Music]
oh there it is michael smith
my best your money 300 million and
seventy dollars brilliant reference from
eddie murphy's raw and how dare you guys
question me for having raw in my eddie
murphy top five anyway uh we got some
great games this week uh what's the
first one let's see which one do i want
to go to first how about
uh cleveland pittsburgh no no okay so we
got let's go green bay tampa bay first
this is something i got some i got
something for you
uh
green bay
versus tampa bay
in tampa
i'm gonna tell you what man
i know you love
aaron rodgers you love aaron rodgers but
you about to see in this game like mike
i have watched every game of tom brady's
career and this is a game where you are
about to see tom brady
show
why he is the best to ever play the
position forget about all your stuff
like aaron rodgers he runs well and he
throws a good ball and all that stuff
low interception rate
tom brady is the best quarterback i have
ever seen and you're gonna see it here
because what i've noticed
through five games tom brady has
basically been clearing his throat it's
like you know the freestyle people are
like adjustment get my lights right one
two turn my levels up turn my levels
down
what's up what's up huh yo yo yeah yo
yeah what what yup that's what he's been
doing through five games
okay
trying to get his rhythm
he's trying to get his rhythm
he's gonna have it here
i like tampa big
in this game
i like tampa big and if you look at
green bay look at their schedule mike
not that impressive hope they really
knocked off who impresses you
nobody
nobody so uh
your boy aaron rodgers your boy aaron
rodgers
don't don't overreact when he struggles
a little bit in this game
and when tampa wins it
decisively all right i want to go to
another one you got anything to say on
that on aaron rodgers anything
no i'll move on i i'm gonna let the game
speak for herself okay all right well
cleveland pittsburgh
we finally have uh and this is all about
brought to you by points back you see
the line there uh pittsburgh undefeated
they're at home uh they're three and a
half point favorites
against their long time rival
the cleveland browns uh that rivals
pause for
what's that
can you really call yeah
yeah man you know what just this
historically you know the last time they
were you know the last time they won in
pittsburgh you know that's on the bronze
one in pittsburgh
it was pretty recent i bet it was recent
yeah about recent you mean you mean this
millennia yeah this millennium what was
the last time the browns went to 2003
2003 what was that 71 in pittsburgh yeah
oh wow
are you sure you gotta recalibrate this
take
are you sure gotta re
i i mean that's what i saw i'm just okay
that's what i saw yeah 2003 that's what
your president said last night different
topic hey that's it
well just because you said it doesn't
mean
that's what i read hey listen that's
right
i don't know
i don't know what kind of stats you have
but look okay 2003. i'm just gonna pick
i'll go pick the steelers anyway because
i think the steelers are a better team
but this is a rival the rivalry they're
separated by about a hundred miles
uh oh so there's a rivalry in proximity
i got you division division components
proximity historically i guess don't we
remember i guess don't we remember what
happened last year nasty play miles
garrett on mason rudolph
so
that kind of stuff used to happen with
the steelers and browns all the time now
i can't remember somebody remember uh
fact check me on this
but i believe there was a um
there was a steeler
who picked up i think i think he picked
up brian's site
just picked him up it was like a
wrestling move picked him up and just
throw them down
like that was they should do that kind
of stuff all the time
unfortunately for the browns they had to
be bystanders they watched the the
steelers win a lot of super bowls in the
uh in the 1970s
and the browns just kind of sat around
and watched because to this day the
cleveland browns not want been to the
super bowl
uh but they will they'll feel good about
their performance on sunday they will
not win this game steelers win it and
they they probably waited by a touchdown
let's go on i got another one on here on
the table
another game what was my other game
i'm trying to remember which one was it
there it is
kansas city and buffalo talking about it
at buffalo
i am not going to call the buffalo bills
there's not an avenger that comes to
mind
when i'm thinking about the bills i
don't think like there
doesn't really match up that way
but they're going to lose mike
i am going with the buffalo bills in
this game
kansas city's favor
buffalo not only will buffalo cover
buffalo will win
you see people overreact all the time so
you're overreacting to the signing of
le'veon bell
some might be overreacting you are you
got you brought your freaking yo oh look
at this oh you know this is who le'veon
bell is you bring out your little you
know uh
little prop
okay that's over here you're
overreacting that i'm breaking your
presence
some people are overreacting
to the
devastating loss that the bills took it
was embarrassing
gosh norman getting pushed around that's
a perfect illustration for what happened
to the bills in tennessee but they're
going to redeem themselves and they are
going to uh beat
kansas city how do they beat kansas city
they're going to really get the uh
defensive minded coach
sean mcdermott
he's good
he's uh doesn't take a lot of chances
mixes up coverages which is what you
have to do
against patrick mahomes
i think they'll be they'll be able to
beat kansas city on sunday i made some
money for you and here's a bonus one
more bonus for you bama
georgia alabama
too bad for uh nick saban hope he gets
better he's got uh coven touching
positive for coving
both of these teams i watched him last
week
bama uh really disappointing on defense
so disappointed that nick saban said man
i think ole miss knows all our signals
they gave up a bunch of points
to ole miss they won a game very
entertaining game
but not a good defensive performance for
the crimson tide then i was watching if
you watched the first half of that
georgia tennessee game not only would
you see a georgia player squirt a
tennessee player with a water bottle
which is kind of ridiculous he got a
flag on that one
but in that first half tennessee looked
like they were all about it second half
they fell apart
i'm going with
georgia to win and the only question
mike smith is
does it count
if kirby smart wins this game that'll be
the first loss nick saban has against
one of his former assistants
does this count
since he's not on the sidelines yeah is
it kyle
uh
yes because if it counts against
steven's record yeah
because it's not like he's not the head
coach you know what i mean he's it's not
like it's an interim coach you know he's
still the head coach so yeah it will
count maybe an asterisk next time
just put a little extra money in your
pocket thank me later you know man i'm
not i don't do it because i'm looking
for the praise i do it just because i
love that's why i love it all right so
i'm just trying
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports